exciting
[Music]
regulating short-term rentals is the
goal of a bill that's making its way
through the legislature now the proposal
would impose state rules and taxes on
properties that are rented out through
companies like airbnb
some are all for it others say though it
is a bad move
sasha loftus joining us now live near
rancho and oaky with what the proposed
changes could mean
sasha
denise as you can see this neighborhood
like so many across the las vegas valley
is peaceful and quiet but those who live
here worry this bill could just really
turn things upside down
so they're asking lawmakers to consider
other options
we're hurt and frustrated laura mcswain
says she's concerned for the future of
her home
we're really really nervous about what
the impact of this is going to be on our
neighborhood
mcneil estates near rancho and oaky is
safe and quiet
but mcswain worries a bill moving
through the nevada legislature
could change that it puts an additional
level of compliance on top of
what they've got ab 363 would establish
rules enforcement guidelines and taxes
for short-term rentals across the state
the part of this is really to enforce
compliance along that
lines so that the jurisdiction knows
who's got short-term rentals experts say
the bill
which proponents call a step in the
right direction
would allow another level of regulation
we just feel like if we'd have been
invited into the conversation sooner
a there wouldn't be the level of
frustration but mcswain
believes it wasn't thought through as it
could allow more rental properties in
one place
and override a city ordinance many
prefer
it allows us to have continuity with our
neighbors you know because we do have an
owner there present on the property
that's why she's asking lawmakers to
reconsider
and understand what this change could
mean for
everyone the thing that i think they
should consider is the fact that we
weren't considered
ab 363 which was introduced by
assemblywoman rachelle wynn
back in march has not gone yet to a vote
through the assembly or the senate we
will of course
keep you posted as it progresses through
the legislature reporting live in las
vegas tonight sasha loftis
8 news now the part of this
is really to enforce compliance along
that
lines so that the jurisdiction knows
who's got short-term rentals experts say
the bill
which proponents call a step in the
right direction
would allow another level of regulation
we just feel like if we'd have been
invited into the conversation sooner
a there wouldn't be the level of
frustration but mcswain believes
it wasn't thought through as it could
allow more rental properties in one
place
and override a city ordinance many
prefer
it allows us to have continuity with our
neighbors you know because we do have an
owner there present on the property
that's why she's asking lawmakers to
reconsider
and understand what this change could
mean for
everyone the thing that i think they
should consider is the fact that we
weren't considered
now ab363 which was introduced by
assemblywoman rachelle
wynn back in march has not gone yet to a
vote
through the assembly or the senate we
will of course keep you posted as it
progresses through the legislature
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now